I am rooted for Will Smith my whole life
I root for this [__] Okay and
now I watch emancipation just to see him
get whooped
Chris Rock took aim at Will Smith during
his Netflix comedy special on Saturday
one year after the actor slapped him at
the Oscars
now a source tells E.T will is
embarrassed and hurt by what the
comedian said about him and his family
during the special Chris referenced the
cheating rumors that surrounded will and
his wife Jada Pinkett Smith in 2020.
then his wife was [__] her son's
friend okay
now
I normally would not talk about this
but for some reason these put that [__]
on the internet I got into an
entanglement with
August that's what I said an
entanglement yes yes
of relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely she hurt him way
more than he hurt me okay and who's he
hit me the special marks the first time
Chris has spoken publicly about the
Oscars slap and people I didn't hurt it
still hurts
I got summertime ringing in my ears
I'm just glad to see after what happened
and all the trauma and stuff that he
emerged stronger I'm glad he's getting a
chance to be seen and appreciated as for
will he addressed the incident the day
after the Oscars on Instagram offering
an apology to Chris a few months later
after the Oscar winner was banned from
attending any Academy events or programs
for a decade he said sorry again in an
emotional video shared to YouTube there
is no part of me that thinks that was
the right way
to behave in that moment now
nessa's will
but people have
olives ads that will has worked on
himself and wants Chris to move on so
that he and everyone else can too E.T
Source says will is also upset that
Netflix gave Chris a platform and thinks
it's distasteful and while will may not
have been into it Chris's friends are
behind him 100
no matter what goes down we support each
other I support freedom of speech
obviously there's no place for violent
Behavior
based on differences in opinions Source
previously told ET Chris said everything
he wanted to say and now he's ready to
move on
[Music]